[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداثهم وتتفاعلوا اخرى البدايه من ولايه
نيفادا الامريكيه حيث يستمر فرز الاصوات
في انتخابات التشديد المصري هي ولايه
المهمه في ضوئي احتياج الديمقراطيه للفوز
بمقعد واحد للسيطره على مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي
لا موسكو التي شددت اليوم على انه لم يتم
الاتفاق بعد على تنديد اتفاقيه الحبوب
الاوكرانيه مؤكده اصرارها على وصول
صادراتها من المواد الغذائيه والاسمده دون
عوائق الى الاسواق العالميه
والى اديس ابابا وترقب بعد توقيع الحكومه
الاثيوبيه وجبهه التراي اليوم اتفاقا يحدد
خريطه الطريق لتنفيذ اتفاقيه السلام التي
توصل اليها الجانبان في جنوب افريقيا هذا
الشهر
في مواضيع الحصاد
[موسيقى]
غداه الانسحاب الروسي من مدينه خيرسون
القوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها استحوذت على
معدات عسكريه روسيه وتبدا بازاله الالغام
وفي دومباس معارك تحتدم في محور مطار
دونيسكو وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ترصد
استخدام القوات الاوكرانيه اليات عسكريه
الصنع جنوبيه البلاد واكيف تتوقع تحول
الاستراتيجيا مع وصوله نتنياهو للحكم
قبل اسبوع من انتهاء مده تطبيق اتفاق
الحبوب كيف تكثف اتصالاتها لتمديده عاما
اضافيا على الاقل وتوسيعه ليشمل موانئ
امريكا
[موسيقى]
بعد خلافات مخيمت على جوله مفاوضات نيروبي
اثيوبيا وجبه تحرير تكرايت وقعان وثيقه
لترتيبات الامنيه في تثبيت اتفاق السلام
تشمل انهاء الاعمال العدائيه ونزع اسلحه
الميليشيات الوسيط الافريقي يقول ان
التنفيذ سيبدا فورا لايصال المساعدات وادي
سبب تلتزم بدمج الفصائل المسلحه وحل لاي
نزاع سلميا
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا المشهد الاحدث لنتائج
الانتخابات
الامريكي
حتى اللحظه يكفي ان يفوز الديمقراطيون
بمقعد واحد من اجل الحفاظ على السيطره على
مجلس الشيوخ بينما يقترب الجمهوريون من
حصد الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب وان كان
الفارق بينهم وبين الديمقراطيين ليس كاسحا
وفي رساله كشفت عنها الكشف عنها موقع
بوليتيكو يقول وعدده من اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
المؤيدين للترامب انهم يشعرون جميعا بخيبه
امل لان الماده الاحمر لم يتحقق وهناك
اسباب عده وراء ذلك لاستطلاع رايكم بشان
هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
برايكم لماذا لم يتحقق المد الجمهوري او
ما تعرف بالموجه الحمراء في الانتخابات
59% اعتبروا دخولها ترامب على خط الحمله
الانتخابيه العامل الاكثر تاثيرا في عدم
تحقيق المد الجمهوري بينما قال 13%
الحزب الديمقراطيه ومرشحه هي العامل لابرز
فيما حدث اما 28% فقد رجحوا خوفا الناخبين
الامريكيين على المسار الديمقراطي في
بلادهم هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه لقاءنا على
المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
تتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
اسئله ما بعد تكرار تعرض قواعد عسكريه
اسرائيليه الاقتحام لاقتحام وسرقه اسلحه
وذخائر ما الذي تخفيه الملابسات واين تتجه
التحقيقات وهل تتعزز الشقوق بوصول الاسلحه
الاسرائيليه الى مجموعات فلسطينيه فضه
[موسيقى]
قال مصدر في مكتب رئيس الاداره الاقليميه
العسكريه في خرسان الجزيره ان السلطات
الاوكرانيه بدات اجراءات الاستقرار في
منطقه خرسون وان اعمال ازاله الالغام في
الارياف المحرره قد بدات بالفعل وكانت
المتحدثته باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه نتالي همنيوك قد قالت ان قوتي
بلادها اكتشفت دبابات ومدافع ومعدات روسيه
اخرى في الاراضي المحرره في الجنوب بعد
فشل الروس في عبور نهر النيبر بها اثناء
الانسحاب ياتي ذلك مع احتدام المعارك في
اقليم دوباس وتحذير المتحدث باسم القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه من هجمات صاروخيه وجويه
روسيه محتمله على مناطق واسعه في البلاد
تعود صفارات الانذار لتدوي في العديد من
مدن ومقاطعه اوكرانيا
بضربات جويه وصاروخيه روسيه وذلك بحسب
المتحدثين باسم قياده القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه
فتمت حاله ترقب تلقي بظلالها على مختلف
الجبهات لمرحله ما بعد معركه خرسان لا
سيما في ظل تصريحاتنا برئيس مجلس الامن
القومي روسي
بان بلاده لم تستخدم بعده ترسنتها الكامله
ولم تقصف كل اهداف العدو المحتمله فكل شيء
في وقته بحسب تعبيره في مقاطعه خرسان بدات
القوات الاوكرانيات تمشيط المناطق التي
انسحبت منها القوات الروسيه لازاله
الالغامي والمتفجرات مؤكده حصولها على
غنائم كثيره بسبب ما وصفته بالانسحاب
الفوضوي للجيش الروسي من تلك المناطق
ان احدث واعنف الاشتباكات كانت من نصيب
الجبهه الشرقيه لا سيما في مقاطعه دونيتسك
فيؤكد الانفصاليون المولون لروسيا انهم
يواصلون التقدم في محور مطار دونيتك
الدولي وانهم على وشك السيطره على بلده
بربمايسك التي يمكن وصفها بخط الدفاع
للقوات الاوكرانيه عن المناطق التي لا
تزال تحت سيطرتها شمال غربي المقاطعه في
المقابل ذكرت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
انها صدى الثمانيه محاولات التقدم من
القوات الروسيه على محاور القتال في هذه
المقاطعه بما في ذلك محور بيرف مماسك اما
في لوجان المقاطعه الثانيه في اقليم دون
بس فقال الحاكم الاوكراني ان جيش بلاده
استعاده السيطره على 11 بلده منذ سبتمبر
الماضي وانه مازال يتقدم لكن ببطء بسبب
الالغام التي زرعتها القوه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
لاحقا في الحصاد مصنف الضوء على الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لخرسون ونسال خبيرا عسكريا
عن المسارات الميدانيه المحتمله في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وفي سياق الميداني ايضا تحاول اوكرانيا
منذ بدء الحرب اقناع اسرائيل بمدها بنظام
الدفاع الجوي المعروف بالقبه الحديديه لكن
حكومه يير لبيد امتنعت عن ذلك خوفا من
اثاره غضب روسيا وخلال الحمله الانتخابيه
قال بنيامين نتنياهو انه سينظر في امكانيه
تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح ما ادى الى حاله
ترقب بشان التحول الذي يمكن ان تشهده
السياسه الاسرائيليه بهذا الخصوص
اليه عسكريه مصفحه اسرائيليه الصنع في
خدمه الجيش الاوكراني بمنطقه خرسن هذه صور
نشرتها هيئه البث الاسرائيلي نقلا عن
صفحات الاوكرانيه ترصد انتشار الاسلحه وهي
لمصفحات من نوع امير من انتاج شركه
الاسرائيليه الخاصه غايه لم يذكر اي شيء
عن طريقه وصول هذه الاسلحه الى ساحه
المعارك باوكرانيا لكن اعين الاوكرانيين
تتجه من بدايه الحرب نحو سلاح اسرائيل اخر
اكثر من مره طلبت اوكرانيا اسرائيل بمدها
بهذا السلاح نظام الدفاع الجوي المعروف
بالقبه الحديديه
يتوقع الاوكرانيون ان القبه الحديديه يمكن
ان تساهم في التصدي لهذه الصواريخ الروسيه
التي تبقى اكبر تحدي تواجهه كيف في الحرب
حاليا مارس الرئيس الاوكراني
ضغوطا قويه على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لدفعها الى تسليم بلاده القبه الحديديه في
خطاب موجه الاسرائيلي في مارس الماضي تحدث
زنسكي الى النواب الاسرائيليين بلغه فيها
بعض التقرير وتسائل باستغراب عن رفض
اسرائيل تسليما بلاده قبه الحديديه وذهب
الى حد تشبيه ما يحدث في بلاده بالهلوكس
لكن ذلك لم يكن كافيا لتغير الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
تل ابيب الحسابات اكثر تعقيدا مما يطرحه
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا لكنها لم تذهب
ابعد من ذلك لكي لا تغضب موسكو
اسرائيل
على اهداف ترانيه تحت اعين انظمه الدفاع
الجوي الروسي
العامل الثاني الذي يحدد موقف اسرائيل هو
وضع من بقي من اليهود في روسيا وضمان
تسهيلات بشان هجرتهم الى اسرائيل اما
العامل الثالث فهو الاتفاق النووي
الايراني والدور الذي يمكن ان تلعبه روسيا
بهذا الشان لهذه العوامل لم تغير حكومه يا
ايرلابيد موقفها حتى عندما قال زينيسكي ان
ايران زودت روسيا بالفي طائره مسيره من
نوع شاهد لكن بنيامين نتنياهو قال خلال
حمله الانتخابيه انه سينظر في امكانيه مد
اوكرانيا باسلحه لم يحدد ما هي هذه
الاسلحه هل هي القبه الحديديه ام اسلحه
اخرى
في اسرائيل قوله انه يعتقد ان تحولا
استراتيجيا يلوح في الافقي مع عوده الى
السلطه
ويستعد لتسلم السلطه لا يعرف هل كان حديث
مفهوم مجرد دعايه انتخابيه ام انه جاد في
تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح والمغامره باثاره
غضب موسكو التي هددت بوضوح بانها ستعيد
النظر في علاقتها باسرائيل في هذه الحاله
يضمرنا من موسكو السيد سيرجي ستروكان محرر
الشؤون الدوليه لصحيفه كوميرسنت ومن تل
ابيب السيد دان شفتان رئيس مركز دراسات
الامن القومي بجامعه حيفا مرحبا بكما سيد
تركي عفوا كيف تفهمون ظهور اليات مصفحه
اسرائيليه تستخدمها القوات الاوكرانيه على
الارض
عامل واتس سبرايز في الحقيقه لم اتفاجا
عندما استمعت الى هذه الاخبار ولكن النقطه
المثيره للاهتمام مع بروز هذه الاخبار
يمكننا ان نقول ان الرد لم يكن على مستوى
هنا في موسكو ما من تصريحا رسمي ولم يتم
تناقش بهذا الموضوع بنفس الطريقه
كالطريقه التي تنقش بها الامدادات
بالاسلحه القادمه من الولايات المتحده
وهناك اسباب لان الاسباب هي لان هذه
المصفحات واذا ما كانت بالفعل قد قدمت الى
اوكرانيا نحن نتحدث عن ارثي الحكومه او
تركه الحكومه الاسرائيليه همم
التي سوف تنتهي الان وهذه الحكومه كانت
تحاول ان ترسي توازنا بين اوسكو وكيف
وبالتالي يمكننا ان نتخيل انه في مرحله
معينه كانت هذه الحكومه قد اتخذت قرارا
بتزويد الاوكرانيين بالمركبات المصفحه هذه
وايضا النقطه الثانيه بعد بروز هذه
الاخبار السؤال التالي ما الذي ياتي بعد
ذلك وكيف سوف يفسر الطرفان هذا الموضوع
اود ان اشدد على نقطه اساسيه واكرر انهما
من تصريحا رسميا روسيا بهذا الخصوص ما
الذي يعنيه ذلك يعني ذلك ان روسيا لا تود
ان تضخم الاخبار والعمليه لان روسيا تضعوا
بعض الامال على الحكومه القادمه
لبنيين نتنياهو
السيد سرقيه خاصه بان نتنياهو لماح بلان
بانه سيدس تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح اسمع
راي السيد دان شفتان في تل ابيب سيدان اذا
همم السيد سرقيه لم يتفاجا من ظهور اليات
عسكريه مصفحه اسرائيليه الصنع تستخدمها
القوات الاوكرانيه السؤال متى وكيف زودت
اسرائيل الجيش الاوكراني بهذه الاليات
اسرائيل
لا تاتي مباشره من اسرائيل بل هي اا مصنعه
المهم هو ان هذه الاسلحه ليس من شانها ان
تقررها نتيجه هذه المواجهه اسرائيل لديها
منظومه مضاده للصواريخ متقدمه للغايه وعلى
الارجح لن تقدمها لم تقدمها الحكومه
السابقه ولم تقدمها الحكومه التي سوف تشكل
حيث ان اسرائيل
مع ايران وبالنسبه الى هذه المواجهه
اسرائيل بحاجه لا تتدخل روسيا بالضربات
الاسرائيليه في سوريا وفي غرب العراق
الاسرائيلي هو في غايه الاهميه بحيث انه
برايي ما من حكومه اسرائيليه سوف تسمح
بهذا النوع من الاسلحه الاسلحه التي يمكن
ان تغير مسار الحرب الحكومه لن تقبل ان
تزود اوكرانيا لهكذا اسلحه اتفاجا اذا ما
حصل ذلك وهذا بالرغم من حقيقه ان اوكرانيا
اليوم اتخذت خطه او خطوه ضد اسرائيل من
خلال التصويت ضد اسرائيل على مستوى
المتحده بشان مساله مهمه وبالتالي لا ارى
ان المعايير الاسرائيليه بهذا الخصوص سوف
تتغير في المستقبل
بقياده نتنياهو بتزويد همم اوكرانيا
بانظمه القبه الحديديه اذن كيف تفهمون
تلميحات نتنياهو بانها بان حكومته ستدرس
موضوع تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
في ذا فويس
السياسه ومنطق السياسه هو كالتالي
المرشحون السياسيون الذين يتنافسون للوصول
الى السلطه يدلون بتصريحات من اجل ان
يكسبوا اصوات الناخبين ولكن ما ان يفصلوا
الى مراكز القياده يتصرفون بطريقه مختلفه
عندما نتحدث عن اسلحه ما هي هذه الاسلحه
الهايمر على سبيل المثال هي شيء والمركبات
المصفحه هي شيء اخر اسرائيل لم تتخطى
الخطوط الحمراء في العلاقه مع روسيا حتى
مع الحكومه السابقه ولكن اذا ما كنا نود
ان نتوخد الدقه في حديثنا نعرف انه في
خلال
همم عهدي الصادق او الحكومه السابقه قيل
انه اذا ما كانت ايران تزود المسيرات
لروسيا لماذا لا نقوم بتزويد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه لا اقول ان هذا هو موقف رئاسه
مجلس الوزراء ولكن هناك اصوات برزت على
المستوى الحكومي بهذا الشان باضافه الى
السوق همم فهم بالنسبه الى المحرقه
وكان هناك سوء تفسير لما قاله السيد
البروف ولكن اللي حزني
الحظ هذا الوقت قد انتهى ونحن لدينا
توقعات مرتفعه بنسبه الى حكومه نحن نعرف
انه حليف للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ويتعين عليه ان يدعي بتصريحات بشانه همم
ان اسرائيل هي جزء من هذا التحالف ولكنه
يتمتعه بالحكمه وانا متاكد من انه لن
يؤدي الى التاث سلبا على المصالح الق
الاسرائيليه من خلال ارسال همم القبه
الحديديه الى اوكرانيا او اسلحه متقدمه
في تل ابيب سيدان حتى الان اسرائيل صمت
امام الضغوط الغربيه وخاصت من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالسلاح ما هي محددات الخطوط الحمراء التي
تحدثت عنها انت والسيد سيرجي بنسبه لتزويد
اسرائيل باي سلاح كان لاوكرانيا لمواجهه
روسيا باقتضاب لو سمحت
التوتر
انا اتفق بشكل كامل مع السيد استروكن في
تحليله بشانه مسؤوليته اسرائيل
ولا اعتقد في الوقت نفسه انا اسرائيل من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حيث ان الضغط
الى الامريكيين هو ان تقول اسرائيل بعض
الامور على مستوى الامم المتحده مرتبطه
بالبعد بالاخلاقي والقانوني حول ما يحصل
في اوكرانيا ولكن الضغط في معظمه على
اسرائيل ياتي من الاوكرانيين اولا ومن
الراي العام بشكل
الاسرائيليين اعتدوا هذه الضغوط
والاعتبارات في الجانب الاخر هي مهمه
للغايه وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان دفتر الراي
العام من شانه ان يغير الموقف الاسرائيلي
صحيح ان روسيا وايران
تتقاربان الان
وهذا يمكن ان يكون جديا للغايه في
المستقبل ولكن امل ان ليس فقط اسرائيل سوف
تكون حاضره بعدم تخطي الخطوط الحمراء بل
ايضا روسيا يجب ان تتنبه لعدم المضيء
بعيدا ليس فقط لان سكران
روسيا مهتمه بان يكون لديها ايران نوويه
في حدودها الجنوبيها هناك مسؤوليه على
الطرفين وهذه المسؤوليه هي التي سوف تسود
في نهايتها شكرا لكم
قال الكريم لان الرئيس ابن دي مربوطن بحث
هاتفيا مع الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم
الرئيسي العديد من القضايا المطروحه على
جدول الاعمال الثنائي وبحسب الكريم فان
الاتصال ركز على التعاون في المجالات
السياسيه والاقتصاديه والتجاريه بما في
ذلك قطاع النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه كما تم
الاتفاقه على تكثيف الاتصالات بين
الادارات الروسيه والايرانيه ذات الصله
جهتها اكدت الرئاسه الايرانيه ان الرئيس
ابراهيم رئيسي رحب في الاتصال الهاتفي مع
نظيره الروسي برغبه موسكو في تعزيز
التعاون الاقتصادي مع ايران والترسيخي
روابط البنيه التحتيه بما في ذلك تطوير
خطوط النقل في منطقه اوراسيا معتبران ان
ذلك
تطوير العلاقات التجاريه على المستوى
الاقليمي ونقلت الرئاسه الايرانيه عن
الرئيس بوتن تاكيده على الموقع الجغرافي
الخاص لايران مشيرا الى ان ممر شمال جنوب
ونظرا لما له من تا في تقليص زمني وتكاليف
النقل يمكن ان يتحول الى طريق بجاذبيه
الاقتصاد وتجاره العالميين
[موسيقى]
قبل ثمانيه ايام من انتهاء مده تطبيق
اتفاق الحبوب 9 كيف الى تمديد الاتفاق
وتوسيعه ليشمل موانئ ميكولايف لكن موسكو
تشترط الموافقه على التمديد بتصدير
منتجاتها الزراعيه اما الوسيط التركيه
فيرفض ان يكون هناك حد زمني بل يتطلعوا
الى ان يؤسس الاتفاقه طريق سلامه
مطلب في كلمه التمديد فذاك ماسجد العمل
باتفاقيه ينقضي اجلها رسميا بعد ايام
امكن الصيف الماضي ابرام اتفاقيه في
اسطنبول بين روسيا واوكرانيا لتصدير
الحبوب في البحر الاسود برعايه تركيا
والامم المتحده
تضمنت الاتفاقيه تامين الصادرات الحبوب
العالقه في الموانئ الاوكرانيه الرئيسيه
الى العالم لمعالجه ازمه نقص الغذاء
اسهمت المباراه
التي تطاول ملايين البشر
لذلك تسمع من رئيس التركي قبل اسبوع من
انتهاء العمل بالاتفاقيه بان تمديدها
سيكون خطوه صائبه لكن لا ينبغي فيما يرى
الرجل وضع حد زمنيا للالتفاق
ويشير اردوغان ايضا الى امكانيه تاسيس ما
يسميه طريقه سلام من ممر الحبوب ورسم حدود
الله والعمل عليه بشكل جيد كما قال ماذا
الان عن موسكو التي لمحت مرارا الى
استعدادها للانسحاب من اتفاقه اسطنبول ما
لم يتحقق تقدم في معالجته مخاوفها
بحثت الامم المتحده اخيرا مع الروس هواجس
وشكاوى على صله بالاتفاقيه التي علقوا
مشاركتهم فيها الشهر الماضي لبضعه ايام
يبدو ان تقدم قد حصل في جناب بما يسهل
تصدير المواد الغذائيه والاسمده من روسيا
بدون عوائق الى الاسواق العالميه لمكافحه
الازمه الغذائيه
ان تمديد فتره اتفاقيه شحن الحبوب من
الموانئ الاوكرانيه هو ما سيساهم حصرا في
تحسين الوضع الغذائي على مستوى العالم
لا تفتح اوكرانيا تطالب بذلك في كل محفل
اقليمي او دولي
مع السلامه لقد دعوت جميع اعضاء الى
السيان الى اتخاذ كل الاجراءات الممكنه
لمنع روسيا من ممارسه الاعب الجوع مع
العالم يجب ابقاء ممرض تصدير الحبوب من
الموانئ الاوكرانيه بعيدا عن ساحه المعركه
وروسيا ينبغي ان لا تستخدم هذا الممر
كورقه ابتزاز او نقطه استغلال في علاقاتها
الدوليه من يبت الزمن
على مساله التطبيق الكامل لمبادره الشحن
الامن للحبوب والمواد الغذائيه من موانئهم
ويثير الروس في المقابل مساله القيود
المفروضه على تصدير منتجاتهم الزراعيه
النجاح في مبادله هذه بتلك سينعيش الامال
حتما في انفراج القريب لازمه امدادات
الغذاء
يضم لنا من اوصله جلين ديسن استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه ساوث ايست في
النرويج والخبير في شؤون اوراسيا سادين هل
هناك شبهات ابتزاز في الشروط الموضوعه
لتمديد اتفاق الحبوب
في الحقيقه نعم حتى اللحظه الراهنه اتفاق
تصدير الحبوب ركز على ان تعطي روسيا نفاد
الكامل لاوكرانيا للاسواق الدوليه ولكن
روسيا تقول وتحجج ان السبب فشل الاتفاق من
العمل بشكل جيد هو ان الغرب منع روسيا من
الوصول الى الاسواق العالميه بنسبه الى
الاسمده الروسيه والاغذيه الروسيه طبعا
روسيا هي جهه مصدره اكبر من اوكرانيا في
هذا المجال وبالتالي تقول روسيا ان هذا هو
سبب ازمه الغذاء والازمه الانسانيه
الناتجه عن نقص الغذاء هذه الحجه الروسيه
هي تقول ان الغرب يمنع الصادرات الزراعيه
الروسيه من اجل التاثير على المدخلي
الروسي وهذا يؤدي الى ازمه
الغرب في لم يفرض عقوبات مباشره على
الغذاء الروسي ولكن هناك عقوبات على
المصارف وعلى شركات التامين وهنا
الاشكاليه لان فرض العقوبات على المصارف
الروسيه بما او باضافه الى موضوع السوفت
ان هذه العقوبات تؤدي الى عدم عمل هذا
القطاع بشكل جيد وايضا السفن لا يمكنها ان
تتحرك من دون التامين على السفن وعلى
المنتجات وبالتالي هذا هو الابتزاز الذي
اذا امكن همم
امام هذا الواقع ما هي احتماليه استجابه
الاطراف لشروط المطروحه اذن
اه والله
هولندا يبدو انها اطلقت 20 الف قمنا من
الاسمده الروسيه باتجاه افريقيا كانت
عالقه في الموانئ
وقد اطلقت الان وهذا من بين المطالب
الرئيسي بالنسبه الى روسيا ان يقبل الغرب
بعدم منع روسيا من الوصول الى الاسواق
العالميه وهذه نقطه اساسيه ويريد ان هناك
تقدما في هذا المجال ولكن ايضا لدينا
مشكله
مرتبطه الان باستخدام اوكرانيا
الممر
الذي تم تاميره لشني هجمه عسكريه من خلاله
وهذه نقطه اساسيه في المفاوضات شكرا
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي في خطابه امام قمه
اسيان في كمبوديا ان الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
الشامله بين الولايات المتحده ورابطه دول
جنوب شرق اسيا ستتعامل مع اكبر القضايا
ومن بينها حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
مع اطلاق اتفاقيه الشراكه الشامله بين
الولايات المتحده
بين الولايات المتحده
فوائد الشراكه في الاستثمار العالمي في
الاتصال
اوكرانيا
خلال القمه مساله الانشطه الصينيه
شدد على اهميه الشفافيه الكامله بشان
انشطه الجيش الصيني في قاعده ريام البحريه
واضاف البيت الابيض ان الرئيس بيضا ورئيس
الوزراء الكمبودي رحب بخطط اقامه شراكه
استراتيجيه شامله بين الولايات المتحده
ومجموعه اسيان
[موسيقى]
وقات الحكومه الاثيوبيه
في نيروبي وثيقه ترتيبات الامنيه بواسطه
افريقيه تثبيتا لاتفاق السلام بينهما
لانهاء حرب استمرت عامين
خطبه جديده من مجهودي اعاده السلام
التي يعيشها الاقليم منذ عامين بين
الحكومه المركزيه وجبهه التحرير الشعبيه
في نيروبي على اتفاق المكمل للاتفاقيه
التي تم التوصل اليها في بريتوريا في
الثاني من هذا الشهر برعايه الاتحاد
الافريقي ابرز هنود الاتفاق وقف الاعمال
العدائيه وجميع اشكال الاشتباكات العسكريه
وفك الارتباط بها ونزع سلاح المقاتلين
المسلحين
والوصول الى الوضع العادي بحلول الخامس
عشر من نوفمبر على ان تتولى السلطات
المركزيه المسؤوليات الاتحاديه وفقا
للدستور في جميع المجالات بما في ذلك
استئناف الخدمات
نسوا الاسلحه الثقيله يتم بالتزامن معا
انسحاب القوات الاجنبيه وغير التابعه لقوه
الدفاع الوطنيه الاثيوبيه من منطقه
التكرايه وتكوين لجنه مشتركه من الطرفين
لنزع الاسلحه الخفيفه كما نصل اتفاق على
حمايه المدنيين وضمان تحركهم الامن
بالاضافه لضمان سلامه وامن المؤسسات
المدنيه والبنيه التحتيه ويتعاون الطرفان
في تسهيل ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه دون
عوائق مع ضمان امن العاملين فيها بناء على
طلبهم
الاتحاد الافريقي المشرف على تطبيق
الاتفاقيه يعتبرها بدايه صفحه جديده وهامه
في اثيوبيا والقرن الافريقي وحث الوسيط
اوليسيجون وبالسانجو الطرفين على تطبيق
الصارم والدقيق للمتفق عليه تمهيدا لمرحله
البناء المشتركه القادمه
لكل اثيوبيا بقومتها المختلفه وعلى راسها
مساله الحرب والسلام وشكل الدستور
الفدرالي والتزام الطرفين بتنفي تسويه
صعبه تتعلق بملكيه الاراضي الزراعيه في
غرب التجاري والتي تسيطر عليها قوميه
الامر المجاوره منذ الاسامي الاولى للحرب
قبل عامين والاختبار الاول الان هو احترام
الطرفين لتعهداتهما وانجاح الجهود
الانسانيه الراميه لانهاء المجاعه التي
اودت بحيات هو 10% من سكان التراي البالغ
عددهم نحو سته ملايين
وعوده مئات الالاف من الفارين
السفير الامريكي السابق في اثيوبيا السفير
ديفيد ما التحديات امام تنفيذ هذه
الاتفاقيه
هناك تحديات مهمه متعدده من المنظور الخاص
التحدي الاساسيه هو السماح في وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى
اضافه الى المساعدات الطارئه في مجال
الادويه الى اخره والنقطه الثانيه هي
خروجي كل القوات الاجنبيه من اثيوبيا اي
القوات الارتريه التي لا تزال على الاراضي
الاثيوبيه من منظور الحكومه التي القلق
الاساسيه هو نزع سلاح
وفي النهايه دمج العناصر التابعه لجماعه
في القوات المسلحه التي ولكن هذا على
الامدئه في هذه النقطه الاخيره ما الضمنت
في التزام الطرفين بهذه البنود بنود
الطاقيه
الى حد علمي ما من الضمانات بهذا الخصوص
الا في حال تم عقد اجتماع انتهى الان في
نيروبي انا لا اعرف ما اذا كان تم التوصل
الى اي ضمانات ولكن الاتفاق الاساسيه في
بريتوريا لم يتضمن اي اشاره الى مراقبين
الدوليين في تجريح حيث يجري القتال وهذه
النقطه سلبيه لانه هناك اختلافات اساسيه
في وجهات النظر بشان ما يحصل اليوم في
الميدان في منطقه في اقليم وخصوصا بالنسبه
الى تواجد القوات الارتريه التي كانت هناك
لاشهر المتعدده
ان تؤسس لشكل الدستور الفضلي المقبل
انا جوايا
في المستقبل طبعا هناك في اثيوبيا طلب
لدستور الجديد
ومساله تكريت تخرج عن نطاق حدودي
لاننا نتحدث عن منطقه محدوده من الاراضي
الاثيوبيه
شعب الاورومو
وهؤلاء يفضلون الفدراليه امهر همم
المجموعه همم الثانيه
بالنسبه اليهم بفضلون
حكومه مركزيه بشكل اكبر وبالتالي كل هذه
العوامل يجب ان تاخذ بعين الاعتبار
وبالتالي تبرز الحاجه الى مباحثات بين
المكونات السياسيه المختلفه في اثيوبيا
ما هي الاول في في هذا في هذه البنود
بتطبيقها طبعا
الاولويه القصوى الان هي السماح بوصول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى تجغراي
والمساعدات الطارئه بالاضافه الى ارساء
الخدمات الطبيعيه من مثلي الخدمات
المصرفيه وخدمات الاتصال الى اخره
المتطلب الثاني الاساسيه هو ان تخرج كل
القوات الاجنبيه من اثيوبيا اذا ما تم
التوصل الى تطبيق
ان هناك مساحه لتنفيذ هذا الاتفاق اما في
غيابه تنفيذ اي من هاتين المسالتين او
كلاهما لا ارى ان هذا الاتفاق سوف ينجح
شكرا لك السفير الامريكي السابق
[موسيقى]
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي ان احدى قواعده
العسكريه في الجولان السوري المحتل تعرضت
للاقتحامي وسرقه كميه كبيره من الاسلحه
منها الليله الماضيه وافاد بين العسكريون
ان قاعده الصنوبر تعرضت الاقتحام من قبل
مجهولين استولوا على كميات كبيره من
الاسلحه والذخائر
من جهاز الامن العام الشباك ومن الشرطه
تشاركوا في عمليه التحقيق والتنشيط والبحث
وكانت قاعده اخرى في منطقه النقب قد تعرضت
للاقتحام والاستلاء على نحو 30,000 عيار
الشهر الماضي
ويساور الجيش الاسرائيلي والجهات الامنيه
القلق من ان تذهب هذه الاسلحه والذخائر
الى مجموعات مسلحه من المقاومه الفلسطينيه
في الضفه الغربيه
اين من رام الله عماد ابو عواد مدير مركز
القدس الدراسات الاسرائيليه سيد عماد ما
الذي تخفيه
والسرقه لهذه الذخيره الاسرائيليه
مثل هذه الحوادث الكثير من التقارير
الاسرائيليه السابقه اشارت بشكل واضح
في كثير من الاحيان لجنود من جيش الاحتلال
في بيع السلاح وفي استبداله احيانا بنوع
من المخدرات ما يخفى الى الان ربما وفق
الترجيحات مؤخرا ايضا بانه الضغط الكبير
الممارس بحق الجنود خاصه اولئك الذين
ينتمون للطائفه الاثيوبيه او الذين ينتمون
للطائفه الروسيه يعانون داخل الجيش بشكل
كبير الامر الذي يحفظهم باتجاه المشاركه
الامر الثاني هناك شعور بوجود نوع كبير من
الترهل داخل المعسكرات المختلفه للجيش حتى
ان بعض المنظمات مثل تراثها الخماره شارت
بشكل واضح بانه تتحمل المسؤوليه قياده
الجيش عندما لا تعطي اوامر واضحه للجنود
ضروره اطلاق النار في محيط المعسكرات على
اي حراك موجود واشارت التقارير بانه
السرقات من داخل المعسكرات وصلت الى ضعفي
سرقات السلاح خارج المعسكرات من الجنود في
اشاره واضحه الى وجود تورط الى وجود
عصابات ووفقه ما حدث اليوم فان المرجح ان
من شارك في مثل هذه العمليات هي عصابه
كامله لان الرقم كبير جدا
[موسيقى]
هي الجهه التي تشتري
بالمعتاد
اصابع الاتهام بالشكل الواضح الى وجود
مجموعه من الجنود او مشاركه احيانا بعض
الظباط من داخل المعسكرات كل التحقيقات
السابقه كانت تشير هناك تحقيق للقناه 12
كان في العام 2012 نيردفوري عندما قام
بتحقيق كبير وتم الكشف عن وجود ثمانيه من
ضباط جيش الاحتلال الذين شاركوا ببيع هذا
السلاح وشاركوا بنقله وشاركوا بتسهيل
عمليه تسريب الى السوق السوداء وجزء منه
وصل بطبيعه الحال الى الضفه الغربيه وجزء
منه استخدم في عمليات المقاومه ضد جيش
الاحتلال لذلك المتهم بالدرجه الاولى هو
الجيش ثانيا العصابات الاجراميه داخل دوله
الاحتلال دائما ما يشار اليها بالاتهام
اضافه الى ذلك ثابت بانه استطاع بعض
الافراد سواء فلسطينيين او غيرهم التسلل
الى داخل المعسكرات ويربما يعني اخذ بعض
السلاح من هذه المسطرات لكن بكميات كبيره
ثبت دائما وجود عصابه متورطه الجيش جزء
منها همم طيب ربما يعتقد الان او البعض
بان هذا ضرب من الخيال بان يكون هناك
عصابه داخل قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي همم
تسطو على قواعد وتبيع هذه الذخيره
والاسلحه الى ماذا يؤشر هذا
اولا قبل المؤشر جلال هناك قضيه مهمه بانه
الجندي الذي يشارك في الجيش كخدمه بمعنى
فتره العامين هو عمليا يتقاضى ما يعرف
بالراتب قليل جدا لا يكفي لبضعه ايامه
هناك شكاوى مستمره من قبل الاهالي وقالوا
باننا لا نستطيع الاستمرار في الدفع
لابنائنا عندما يذهبون الى المعسكرات
اضافه الى ذلك وجد بانه هناك عنصريه كبيره
ضد بعض الفئات في الجيش خاصه الاثيوبيين
وكذلك الملونين وهنا قيادات وضباط جيش من
الغربيين يمارسون الكثير من العنصريه ضد
الجنود على وعلى ذلك بانه ثلث المنتحرين
في الجيش هم من الطائفه الاثيوبيه رغم انه
نسبتهم في الجيش اقل من واحد في المئه الى
ماذا يؤشر اولا الى حاله الترهل الموجوده
في الجيش ثانيا الى الشعور الجندي بانه
يجب ان يعمل من اجل همم يعني الرزق ومن
اجل ان يكسب المال والت على ظروف الحياه
الصعبه ثالثا هناك نوع مؤخرا من الاتجاه
لدى دوله الاحتلال بانه الوحدات المتقدمه
التكنولوجيه والسايبر يذهب اليها الطلبه
المتفوقون وفي غالبيتهم من الاصول الغربيه
فيما يدفع بالشرقيين باتجاه الوحدات
القتاليه الامر الذي ولد حال من الغضب
الكبير شكرا لدى الشرقيين بشكل عام وهذا
يؤدي الى وجود هذه الحاله التي تترى كم
منذ سنوات مدير مركز القصه دراسات
الاسرائيليه في رام الله شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
كشفت ازمه اف تي اكس عن خضه كبيره تتعرض
لها اسواق العملات المشفره قد تكون الاشد
حده في تاريخها القصير بقدري ما تنطلق هذه
العملات باقصى سرعه فانها تهوي بسرعه
ذاتها في سوق شديده التقلبات عاليه
المخاطر
180 عمله تنتمي للعدد نفسه من الدول
والكائنات السياسيه عمله حقيقيه يمكنك
لمسها وعدها وحملها وصرفها بغيرها من
العملات كل واحده من تلك العملات لها
قواعد وقوانين وسلطه تحكم اصدارها لكن
ومنذ ان ظهرت عمله البيتكوين المشفره عام
2009 فتح الباب امام كل من يمتلك بعض
المعرفه بتكنولوجيا البروكجين ان يقيم
دولته في فضائل الانترنت ويصدر عمله مشفره
الى ان بلغ عددها
10.925 عمله ما يعني ان كل عشر ساعات كان
يستيقظ احدهم من النوم ويقرروا اصدار عمله
مشفره جديده فماذا كانت النتيجه تدفقت
الاموال على سوق العملات المشفره وازداد
الطلب عليها تحت ضغط الدعايه
الاساطير الى ان تجاوزت القيمه السوقيه
العام الماضي ثلاثه دولار ما اجماليه
مبيعات النفط الخامس سنويا في كل انحاء
العالم ومع تراكم المكاسب في اسواق
العملات المشفره جرى فيها ما جرى بالاسواق
الماليه عبر خلق المشتقات فقامت شركات
التداول وصناديق الاستثمار بعمليات دمج
وخلط بين العملات المشفره لانتاج منتجات
او حزم استثماريه جديده للتداول عليها وفي
خطوه تذكر باول شراره لازمه الماليه عام
2008 هوت سوق العملات المشفره وتراجعت
باكثر من 60% في فتره وجيزه وتفاقمت
الخسائر خسائر تناز التريليونار كانت شركه
بنك استثماري متخصص في العملات المشفره
تعرضت للافلاس بعد تكبعها خسائر بنحو
مليار دولار سلسله التي تاسست عام 2017
كانت تمنح عملاها ارباحا سنويا تصل الى
18% في وقت كانت فائده متدنيه وهكذا
اجتذبت الشركه مع غيرها مليارات الدولارات
خلال موجه صعود صاروخين للعملات المشفره
بدعم من توافر السيوله مع برامج التحديث
الماليه وقت ذروه الجائحه كل ذلك كان يتم
في سوق تفتقد القوانين والقواعد التنظيميه
والان ها هي منصه العملات المشفره اف تي
اكس تهوي في المنحدر ذاته اليوم تقدمت
بطلب لحمايه اف تي اكس واف تي اكس امريكا
والميدا من الدائنين بموجب البند الحادي
عشر من قانون الافلاس الامريكي انني اسف
للغايه انا ننتهينا الى هنا امنوا ان نجد
طريقا للتعافي وان يحمل هذا الامر مقدارا
من الشفافيه والثقافه
وهكذا صار الافلاس يثير اسئله بشان كيفيه
عمل ومصير صناعه التمويل الرقميه وعن
المسؤوليه التي يجب ان تتحملها الحكومات
وهل يمكن للدول واقعيا تنظيم تلك الاسواق
والاشراف عليها تجربه تؤكد ان الوقت لا
يزال مبكرا على منحه ثقه الكامله لسوق
عاليه السيوله عاليه المخاطر تشبه سوقا
لبيع قطط سوداء في غرفه مظلمه
[موسيقى]
اقعدوا الان الى التطورات المدنيه في
اوكرانيا وهنا نطرح السؤال ما الاسباب
التي تطفي على منطقه خرسون اهميتها
الاستراتيجيه تقع منطقه على حدود شبه
جزيره القرم بالبحر الاسود وتوفر لموسكو
رابطا من خلال جسر بريا مع شبه الجزيره
التي ضمتها روسيا من اوكرانيا في عام 2014
سيترتب على السعاده
حرمانه موسكو من هذا الممر البري وسيع
يعني ذلك ايضا اقتراب المدفعيه الاوكرانيه
بعيده المدى من شبه جزيره القرد التي
تعتبرها موسكو ذات اهميه حيويه
لمصالحها اهميه المائيه حيث ستعرض امدادات
المياه العذبه لشبه جزيره القرد للخطر
ايضا اذا استعادت اوكرانيا منطقه خرسون
كامله فبعد ان سيطرت موسكو على شبه جزيره
القرد منعت اكياس امدادات المياه عبر قناه
متفرعه من نهر وعندما سيطرت روسيا على
اجزاء ان منطقه خرسون ومنطقه زافيروجيا
المجاوره الى الشرق تحركت على الفور لفتح
القناه وتحتاج روسيا لهذه المياه من اجل
سكان المحليين والمنشات العسكريه وري
الاراضي القاحله في شبه جزيره القرم تضم
منطقه خيرسون مصب نهر النيبرو الواسع الذي
يقسم اوكرانيا وتقع العاصمه الاقليميه
مدينه خيرسون على الضفه الغربيه للنار
وكانت المكان الوحيد الذي توجد فيه روسيا
على الضفه الغربيه وعسست بكثافه قوتها
هناك في الاشهر القليله الماضيه
في حديثنا ايضا عن الاهميه اللوجستيه
لمنطقه خرسون قصفت القوات الاوكرانيه خلال
المعارك الاخيره الجسور فوق النهر لعبقله
قدره موسكو على اعاده التزويد بالامدادات
واذا فقدت روسيا موقعها الوحيد على الجانب
الغربي من النهر فستكون اوكرانيا اكثر
قدره على مهاجمه خطوط الامداد الروسيه
الاخرى وتحدي سيطره موسكو على اجزاء
الاخرى من الجنوب مثل منطقه زافولوجيا
نشير ايضا الى ان منطقه خيرسون التي كان
عدد سكانها كان عدد سكانها قبل الحرب
يتجاوز مليون نسمه تطل على منطقه البحر
الاسود ومن ثم تساعد استعادتها كلاب على
احكام السيطره على بعض المناطق على طول
ساحل البحر الذي يعد شريانا مهما لتصدير
سلاحها الغذائيه للاسواق الخارجيه ثم
اهميه رمزيه ايضا فقد كانت مدينه غرسون
العاصمه الاقليميه الوحيده
التي سيطرت عليها القوات الروسيه منذ بدء
الحرب في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير شباط
الماضي وبالتالي تمثل خساره خلصن ضربه
معنويه كبيره لكريملين ومؤشرا سلبيا على
الخطط الروسيه للسيطره على مدينه نيكولايف
وايضا على اوديسا على الساحل نظام الينا
من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
واستجي العميد حنا امام هذه المعطيات اذا
خيرسون الان اهم همم منطقه بالنسبه
للمعركه في هذه المرحله لروسيا
جلال هي مهمه ولكن بالمعنى المادي نتحدث
عن 24,000 او 27,000 كلم مربع تم استرداد
ما يقارب 9000 كلم مربع غرب الضفه الغربيه
للنهر يبقى الحاجز الطبيعي هو حاجز هل
حاليا حمايه همم
القوات الروسيه وهو حاليا عائق امام اي
عمليه عسكريه اوكرانيه باتجاه الجنوب
اليوم انا اعتقد على هذه الجبهه سيكون
الوضع ستيل ميت يعني وضع ثابت الحركيه قد
تكون
باتجاه الجنوب باتجاه زباله مليته بول هذا
اذا حصل
لاهميه هذه المدينه همم اقليم خرسان كما
قلت يطل على البحر الاسود هو المدخل
والاهم هو منطقه زراعيه مهمه جدا فيها
ثروات جلال حتى على البحر يقال ان هناك
ثروات من النفط والغاز والشابه حتى من
المواد همم الطبيعيه المهمه جدا يبقى
اليوم بالمعنى السياسي بالمعنى السياسي هو
ثالث انسحاب للجيش الروسي مع الرئيس بوتين
صحيح يعني الانسحاب الاول
الانسحاب الثاني قصرا من خركاب والانسحاب
الثالث طوعا بقرار على نجلاء بغياب الرئيس
بوتين وكانه لا يوافق ضنيا ولكنه مرغم على
الموافقه وكانه لا يريد الانسحاب من هذه
المنطقه هذا هو بعد التعبئه الجزئيه وبعد
اعلان ضم خرسون ايضا من ضمن الاقاليم
الاربعه طيب هذا الجزء الذي استعادته اذا
صح التعبير القوات الاوكرانيه من غير سوني
الى اي مدى يمكن ان يعطل مشروع
واستراتيجيه موسكو في هذا الساحل الجنوبي
همم عميد حنا
اولا المرحله الاولى للقوات الاوكرانيه هي
فرض الامن العملاني او امن القوات يعني
اليوم هناك عمليه تنظيف
من كل ما تبقى من الجيش الروسي من انغام
من اليات من زخيره وحتى من مقاتلين قد لم
يستطيعوا العبور الجسد باتجاه الضفه
الشرقيه هذا اول امر مهم اعاده
الترتيب والتنظيم للمرحله القادمه اليوم
عندنا نتحدث على سبيل النساء للحسر عن
صواريخ او رجيمات الهايمارس يعني اليوم
بدل ان تقصف من منطقه بعيده انت اليوم في
مدينه خرسون قادر على ضرب العمق همم في
مدينه في منطقه خرسان الضفه الشرقيه بعمق
ال 80 كيلو متر ماذا يعني هذا الامر يعني
ان لا يمكن للقوات الروسيه ان يكون لديها
تجمعات قياده وسيطره مراكز ذخيره مهمه على
مسافه وعمقه 80 كم ومن هنا اختيارها لمركز
المحافظه المؤقت والذي يبعد 200 كم عن
مدينه غرسون الاساسيه اشرت الى جمود محتمل
في همم الوضع الميداني هل ممكن ان يحرك
هذا الوضع السياسي بتقديره
انا لا اعتقد اليوم من يذهب الى طويله
التفاوض يجب ان يكون مقتنعا ان هذا اقسم
توصل اليه وعليه ان يكون قادرا على ترجمه
المكسب العسكري على الارض على الطاوله
سياسيه بالداخل ما يطلبه الرئيس بوتين
كبير جدا وما تطلبه اوكرانيا صعب جدا
اليوم تحرير كامل الارض لم نزل في المرحله
ثلاث كما يقول فعل رد فعل انا اعتقد هناك
مرحله معينه قد تمر بانتظار الشتاء وما قد
ياتي بشتاء اللهم الا اذا حصل شيء ليس
بالحسبان شكرا العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي
[موسيقى]
مع ختام الحصاد نتوقف عند مشهد من
الولايات المتحده يحمل مفارقات عديده
ويطرح اسئله كثيره
مهاجرون لا يحملون اوراق عمل نظاميه
والمفارقه هنا ان اغلب مرشحي الحزب
الجمهوري في الانتخابات النصفيه التي جرت
قبل ايام بنو حملاته من انتخابيه على
شعارات لمواجهه الهجره
يعملون تحت اشعه الشمس الحارقه وتحت المطر
يعتلون السطوح ويتعاملون مع المنتجات
الكيميائيه يكدحون نهارا وينامون في
شاحناتهم ليلا لانه ليس لديهم مكان اخر
يذهبون اليه يتعرض هؤلاء لسوء معامله
محتمله من قبل اصحاب العمل واحيانا تكون
اجورهم منخفضه او ينالون اقل من ما وعد به
ويهددونهم بتسليمهم لسلطات الهجره اذا
تقدموا بشكوه هي صعوبات الحياه التي تدفع
كثيرين في العالم الى الاختيار ما بين
السيء والاسوا مقابله حياه يامرون ان تكون
كلمه شكرا المتابعه الى اللقاء من الله
ونعم الوكيل
[موسيقى]